always stick to your vision like what
you think is the ultimate goal for
yourself because nobody can tell you
what's right and what's wrong in the
course of your life
[Music]
my name is roddy rich i'm a grammy
award-winning
rapper slash music producer i rap like
lifestyle like i write about
like things that i go through certain
rappers are like storytellers
then certain rappers are like lifestyle
rappers so it's like the things that
they go through and the things that they
see and learn and everything they like
kind of try to pass it down to you
inspiration is definitely
one of the driving forces of my of my
music like it's just something
i'll just be trying to motivate the next
person to be better than me
i feel like regardless of the industry i
just want to build a better life
for my generation i still go back to
where i'm from
and look out you know just making sure
my peers are straight like some of the
guys i grew up with just
making sure they still on track because
it's like it's easy to get
lost in the sauce
i'm just in a place of constant growth
no
i always want to just keep
keep a steady incline always learn how
to
just do better and always be better like
i got this far from
being inspired by something if i could
be that to somebody else i feel like
i live forever
you